okay cool hey everyone how's everyone
feeling we got some energy alright
awesome that that lunch is digested and
you're ready to learn okay so I am
Quincy and I'm going to talk about how
to write technical blog posts the people
will actually read that that actually
read part is important so you may be
wondering why is this developer talking
about writing well I worked as a
journalist for about three years after
college and I would say that technical
blogging was absolutely critical to
people actually realizing that freako
camp existed and to our early community
growth we're a small nonprofit we don't
have like a lot of resources for
advertising or for public relations so
we turn to trying to write articles
worth reading so I've been writing very
actively on both medium and on Quora
and I also edit free code camps medium
publication which publishes a whole lot
of articles on development design and
data science so my goal is for all of
you to walk out of here with both the
confidence and the tools that you need
to be able to write technical articles
that people will sit down and actually
invest the time in reading so there are
really three elements to this first you
need substance second you need to
package that substance for consumption
and third you need to go out and
publicize it so before we get into that
though I want to see why people are
blogging I saw a lot of hands go up
earlier for people who are blogging I'm
just gonna go up right now who is
blogging because they want to impress
future employers okay quite a few all
right who wants to apply recently
learned knowledge one of the best ways
to reinforce your own learning is to
turn around and teach it to somebody
else and it
technical blog post is an excellent way
to do that all right and who just wants
to share their insights with other
developers and kind of pay it forward
quite a few of you and maybe nobody
always they're here because this is a
little immodest but who is interested in
becoming a thought leader in a specific
domain all right yeah you want to so you
want to get on the conference circuit
you want to get on podcast like code
newbie and you want to raise awareness
of your area of expertise great it does
not matter like regardless of your
reason it does not matter really the
goal should be to just get people to
read your articles if you set out to
achieve that one single goal it will
help you with all four of those
objectives let's start with substance
you need to write something that matters
and I will tell you that people quickly
they have all these kind of rules of
thumb about blogging like oh it should
be 600 words and you know just quickly
get it out there and and blog every
single day I don't buy any of that stuff
I really think that it's all about
substance when you have something to say
that's when you open your mouth and you
say it and you can really hone in and
take that substance and turn it into a
whole lot of blog posts this is a guy
named Peter Paul Kosh he is the author
of the popular quirks mode blog and
quirks mode is really awesome because
it's focused just on the quirks between
different browsers and different
versions of browsers so he's he totally
geeked out on the difference between how
JavaScript is processed by Internet
Explorer 10 and mobile safari and opera
and his blog will show you all the
different intricacies of those for when
you're trying to develop cross browser
applications and those considerations so
what did he do he did his homework he
learned a whole lot about this one
subject and he went really deep on it
then he turned around and figured out
ways that he could write about it in
novel ways and that's what you should do
a lot of people may lament that
everything's been written it's all been
done every flavor of breakfast cereal
has been tried reality is there are
always new ways new permutations that
you can toggle and switch around to make
new original spins on old topics a lot
of blog posts are written either from a
hello world absolute beginner
perspective and then a lot of them are
written from I've been coding for 10
years
there aren't enough articles that are
kind of in the middle for example so
experience levels one dimension of which
you can play around then there are a lot
of opportunities for taking something
that's been written in a different
language and blogging about how to do it
in another language or introducing humor
right humor makes your blog post
palatable so use it liberally and you
can even write joke posts that are
basically parroting something but
teaching at the same time so here's the
quick case study want everybody to meet
amber she's a seattle-based marine
biologist by training she got a master's
degree in marine biology and she worked
at Disney surveying the animals and
doing science related to the animals
that the Disney had and its parks and
unfortunately rain biology is a field
that a lot of people want to get into
people love animals it's very
competitive around the holiday season
she found herself with her contract not
renewed to cheer herself up she was
really pumped she's like all right I'm
gonna go see the new Star Wars movie did
anybody see the new Star Wars movie
rogue one okay awesome
so she was really excited because like
the first time it looked like a Star
Wars movie where the protagonist was
female but when she walked out of the
theater she had a weird sense that maybe
the protagonist wasn't the female
character and sure enough she did the
math and she counted up all the words
and she found that the main character
actually didn't didn't speak as many
lines as some of the other characters
and she also noticed that there were far
fewer female characters in that movie
than there were male characters and she
was like well this seemed
like it was marketed as a movie you know
to women to try to get more women in the
Star Wars so she looked at all the other
blockbuster movies like though the top
ten grossing movies of 2016
she built a bunch of data visualizations
she wrote scripts to dive through and
count all the dialogue and assign the
gender to the different characters and
she built this beautiful series of data
visualizations and so she had the
substance she just needed to sit down
and write about it and that's what she
did I coached her through it and we
wrote a medium publication and her
article was huge it got picked up by
Mashable it got picked up by IGN a whole
lot of International Press and it raised
awareness of this issue so she was able
to use her scientific skills from being
a marine biologist kind of poured it
over to doing data visualization the
data science and as a result a whole lot
of employers and prospective freelancing
contracts came her way from this article
so there's just one blog post right you
only need to write one good blog post if
it has good substance so it's a lot of
hard work expect to invest a lot of time
and energy good blog posts don't come
easily not good technical blog posts the
second lesson I want you to all walk
away from is that packaging is important
the way you take your substance the way
you package it and present it to the
reader is very important this is the
most expensive vodka in the world I'm
not a vodka connoisseur or anything but
when I saw these bottles I was
immediately sucked in I wanted to learn
more about it right it's packaging well
what's the packaging on a blog post you
got your headline you've got your lead
image you have the formatting of the
text and the sub heads and the pull
quotes and then you've got the platform
that you publish it in all of those
things are considerations that you
should keep in mind when it comes to
packaging your technical blog post I
want to talk about headlines
specifically because I want to point out
that that is all that about 95 percent
of people are going to read
they're scrolling through their their
Twitter feed while they're sitting on
the toilet or while they're holding the
handle on a bus and they're like do I
want to read this do I want to read this
they read your headline and it's up to
your headline to entice them to read the
rest of your article so has anybody
heard the old adage by Abe Lincoln about
chopping down trees so if I had eight
hours to write a technical blog post I'd
spend the first six sharpening the
headline it's true the headline really
is empires have been built on the backs
of headlines has anybody heard of
BuzzFeed you know and there's a science
to it
there's a lot you can you can read up on
and you can a/b test your headlines you
can show them two of your friends and
just try to figure out if people who
click on them it's really that important
and then the images humans are highly
visual creatures like our our visual
cortex is one of the biggest parts of
our brain so you've got a cater to that
you've got to show people images 86% of
the top blog posts have images in them
and on average they'll have at least one
image every 350 words some of you may be
like well I can't afford a license
really good images well there's great
news there are so many generous
photographers out there who take their
images and turn them to Creative Commons
or even Creative Commons 0 which doesn't
even require attribution you can just
splash their photo up on there and this
website pixels you can search around and
find images that are public domain or
Creative Commons license on a number of
platforms so in terms of formatting you
need to be sure that you don't get the
Picard Ian wall of text right people
will bounce if they see English comp 101
eight sentence paragraphs remember
reddit is only an alt tab away so be
sure that you show them nice short
paragraphs nice short sentences it's not
a matter of sounding like
dumbing it down a lot of people look at
it that way you can express the exact
same concepts in much simpler words and
you can use short paragraphs and you can
use white space you can use subheads
you can use pole quotes all those things
to break that up the platform you
publish it on makes a big difference
these are some of the most popular ways
that people publish their technical blog
posts so I'm a big fan of medium it's ad
free it's it's user supported and it
allows for easy export of your content
and it has a built-in audience that's
quite big they get like 86 million
visits a month and then you can also
post on blog on your own private blog
you can just use a github pages blog and
create get your own domain and set it up
that way too there are trade-offs
associated with all these if you happen
to have all a lot of friends on LinkedIn
or if you happen to have all a lot of
friends on Facebook that might be a good
place to publish to notice a lot of
celebrities have been blogging on
directly on Facebook so here's another
case study this is Oh Hans he is a web
developer in Lagos Nigeria and he
created this amazing guide to flexbox
the only problem was he just created
markdown files and folders and pushed it
to github and left he left it at that
well you can go one step further and
actually write an article a proper
article and that's what I convinced him
to do so if you look at this he has a
nice headline that accurately describes
it's not a clickbait headline what the
article is and then he's got some images
he breaks up the text with tweets and
he's got subheadings he's got short
paragraphs short sentences it's easy to
read it's it's a breezy read even though
it's about 10,000 words right like
you're gonna be reading for about an
hour and you're literally going to learn
all about flexbox and it may seem like
well who has time to sit down and read
an hour-long article about flexbox
people read 500 word blog posts right
well actually this is one of the most
popular technical articles ever
published it's been viewed more than a
hundred thousand times and as a result
he got an enquiries from book publishers
he even had some
for platforms reach out to him who
wanted him to create some workshops on
flexbox so yeah he had substance he knew
flexbox very well he packaged it
properly and he profited lesson number
three publicized you may have heard the
expression in software development the
last 10% of the work takes 90% of the
time well let me tell you publicizing
your work is the last 10% and it's gonna
take 90% of your time
there is no build it and they'll come
you need to go out and tell people that
this exists and you need to actively
advocate for people to read your own
article one place you can put it is
hacker news I like to call it the hacker
news lottery because honestly there's
like AI could publish like the best
article I've ever written on Hacker News
and nobody would notice or some random
article that I published might show up
at the top one day because somebody
submitted it's like totally random and I
can tell you I see totally random things
on Hacker News you see totally random
things at the top of Reddit sometimes
but if you keep submitting every every
time you submit that's a lottery ticket
right and you need to pay to win or you
need to play the win so you can also
target specific Facebook groups there
are a lot of really big Facebook groups
some of them local to your city maybe
your alumni group on Facebook from your
university or from your high school
share it with your friends that way
groups are a great way to spread it you
can also use LinkedIn people do use
LinkedIn groups it does send like email
digests people might see it and then I
would also say use other people's
audiences so if you publish on a medium
publication you're immediately kind of
hijacking the audience of that
publication for a moment to get their
attention if you publish it in Forbes or
TechCrunch or some of these other major
publications that actually submit kind
of op-ed reader posts and and you can
actually become a writer for Forbes or a
writer for TechCrunch and publish right
on there and that way you're borrowing
their credibility as well as their
audience
so just to summarize three things to
remember create technical blog posts
that are substantial package them for
consumption and publicize them like
crazy if you do that you'll write blog
posts that people will actually sit down
and read thank you very much
[Applause]